انقسام في الكويت حول قرار الصحه بخصوص
ضوابط الاعلانات الطبيه ومذيع سوري يطرد
ضيفن تركيا على الهواء مباشره ورد السلطات
التركيه اعتقال المذيع ومدير القناه
وتفاصيل القبض على سارقي فيلا محمد صلاح
واشتركه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في قرار صدر عن وزاره الصحه في الكويت
وبرجع عليه التعليقات والقرار يتعلق
بالاعلانات الطبيه وبحدد ضوابطها عبر 26
ماده صعب يعني نعددهم الان كلهم لكن خليني
اقول لكم خلاصه المحظورات في هذه اللائحه
فاولا منع الاعلان عن اسعار الخدمات خارج
المنشات الطبيه يعني ممنوع اي اعلانات
تذكر اسعار الخدمات وممنوع كمان العروض
والخصومات او تقسيط او مثلا تسهيلات ممنوع
كمان الترويج للوهم الطبي بانه مثلا يدعي
طبيب او منشاه انهم الافضل او الوحيدين او
الاجدد او يسمون نفسهم خبراء مثلا في كذا
او طبيب المشاهير وبالنسبه للتصوير في
الاعلانات القرار كمان حط له ضوابط فقال
انه ممنوع تصوير المرضى الا بموافقتهم
وبما لا يخالف الذوق العام واظهار الحد
الادنى من جسم المريض من دون تحديد هويته
وبما يحافظ على خصوصيتهم في مواد ثانيه في
القرار تكلمت عن منع الاعلانات عن الادويه
او المستحضرات غير الحائزه على ترخيص ومنع
الطعن في زملاء المهنه كمان وتحديد حساب
واحد على كل منصه السوشيال ميديا لكل جهه
للاعلان موضوع الاعلانات الطبيه هذا عامل
جدل في الكويت من فتره والمنصات كانت
مليانه باصوات معترضه على الاعلانات هذه
واغلبهم على فكره كانوا من المحامين وهذه
الايام من بعد قرار وزاره الصحه كثير من
هؤلاء سعيدين ومؤيدين للقرار ومعاني اليوم
عشان نتكلم اكثر في الموضوع احد المطالبين
من زمان في ضوابط للاعلانات الطبيه من
الكويت المحامي الاستاذ الدكتور فايز
الكندري اهلا فيك معانا دكتور فايز حضرتك
من المؤيدين لهذا القرار ومن المطالبين في
حتى من قبل ايش كان سبب اصرارك على هذا
المنع او الضوابط خلينا نقول
مساء الخير بدايه شكرا على الاستضافه
واتاحه الفرصه لتصديق الضوء على القرار
وزاري الخاص بوضع الضوابط خاصه بالاعلانات
الطبيه طبعا انا من المؤيدين ومن المؤيدين
بشده وانا اعتقد بان هذا القرار اتاخر
ولكن صدور قرار افضل من لا صدوره نحن
اليوم عن امرين الامر الاول نتحدث عن
الاخلاقيات ممارسه اي مهنه والامر الثاني
عن ضمان سلامه اختيار المريض الطبيب
المعالج دون ان يمارس عليه اي ضغط ايا كان
صورته وايا كان ايا كان نوع باي شكل من
اشكال ممارسه المهن الحمى الحره يجب ان
يتم النظر اليها بعين الاعتبار بانها
بعيده كل البعد عن التجاره بعيده كل
الترويج والتسويق والدعايه والاعلام فمن
يمارس مهنه حره شان الطبيب وكذلك المحامي
لا يمكن بحال ان يسمح له ان يقوم بالترويج
والدعايه والتسويق لنفسه ولخدماته على
اعتبار لما فيه ليست تجاره وانما يقوم
بممارسه مهنه حره فهي تلقى طبيب من المريض
وما يتلقاه المحامي من الوكيل او العميل
جاز التعبير ليس اجر وليس ربح ولكن يطلق
عليه اتعاب اللفظ المستخدم لدلاله باننا
نتحدث بعيده كل البعد عنك دكتور فايز برضو
يعني لا فيها ربح وفيها خساره وفيها
منافسه ويعني اكيد حتى بين المحاميين وبين
الدكاتره يعني كثير ناس بيقولوا انه طب
ايش المشكله انه واحد يحط اعلان عن ايش
مثلا بيسوي او بيفور انا مثلا هذا يعني
خصوصا بالنسبه للدكاتره يعني هذا شيء
عالميا بيعملوه الدكاتره
نعم دعينا فقط ان اوضح التفرقه المهمه ما
بين من يمارس المهنه ومن ما بين ملاك
العيادات الخاصه ملاك المراكز الطبيه
الاهليه والعيادات والمستشفيات الملاك ام
تجار وهذا عمل تجاري اليوم انشاء
المستشفيات القياس الخاصه والعيادات
الخاصه والمختبرات الاهليه هذا يعتبر عمل
تجاري بحكم القانون ولا جدال بانه يمارس
عمل تجاري بهدف الربح لاجل كذلك ولكن
عندما نتحدث عن طبيب يمارس ويجب ان نقتاد
ويجب ان نتقيد بحدود الاداب ممارسه المهنه
المشكله تكمن في ان العديد من الاطباء
اصبحوا ملاك لهذه المستشفيات وملاك لعادات
الخاصه فوقعنا بالمحظور فنسب انه هو هو
طبيب وليس مالك نعم انت الان فتحت عياده
وفتحت مستشفى ولكن ايضا نعم تباشر عمل
تجاري ولكن عندما تعلن عن نفسك تعلن نفسك
انت اليوم كطبيب فبالتالي يجب ان تتجنب
بقدر المستطاع اي ظهور يمس المهنه يمكن
انا بالفتره ليست بعيده في شهر 9 العام
الفائض غرات بان هذا الامر لا يليق بهم
شخصيا يعني اليوم لما نقول
لك اياها دكتور فايز يعني هذا الشيء
عالميا بيسووه كثير من الاطباء بيسووه
عالميا وخصوصا تحديدا اطباء التجميل وهذا
النوع من الخدمات المقدمه فيعني وين
المشكله
المشكله الاساسيه الله يسلمك بين الاعلان
لا باس فيه لكن الاعلان بحيث ان لا يخرج
عن الذوق العام من جهه ولا يخرج على
ما حدث في الكويت للاسف الشديد ان هناك
حدث في ان في الطرق العامه بدات تنتشر
يعني الصور
بشكل ملفت للنظر وبداوا يعني الناس يعني
تشبههم ذات الموجودين في الشوارع العامه
وهذا امر امر لا يمكن قبول يعني
من حقه ان يعلن عن عيادته
عن تخصصه لا باس في ذلك لكن هناك في حد
للذوق العام هناك في حد يجب ان لا نتجاوزك
فيما يتعلق في المهن الحره ما حدث في
الكويت في فتره سابقه لا يمكن قبوله ولم
اجد في اي دوله من الدول
المتقداز التعبير التي لا تعتبر متقدمه
لكن لا يمكن ان نقبل بان صور اطباء
[موسيقى]
هناك منافسه اصبح للفشنستات بانتشار صور
اطباع للطرق العامه بشكل ملفت للنظر يعني
دكتور فايز انه فعلا في اطباء كثير تحولوا
لنجوم خصوصا حتى على السوشيال ميديا وبما
انك انت ذكرت موضوع المشاهير وما الى ذلك
ايش مصير الاعلانات اللي هي بتم عن طريقهم
انه مثلا زياره عياده اسنان زياره على هذا
التجميل اي زياره عياده مثلا طبيب اطفال
وتكون مثلا هي اعلان ايش مصير هذا النوع
من الاعلانات
الان بعد هذا القرار يعني بدانا نضع ضوابط
خاصه حتى الاعلان الغير مباشر في ايضا في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ما بين المسؤوليه المجتمعيه الملقعه عاتق
المحقق العاتق الدكتور الملحعه علاقاته
الطبيب على مناطق المهندس في نشر الثقافه
العامه في مشاركه المجتمع في القضايا
العامه في الراي العام هذا هذا مطلوب ولكن
يجب ان لا تستخدم هذا الامر للتدليل
والترويج عن مهنتك وبالتالي تقوم بالدعايه
لنفسك بشكل ايش مباشر او غير مباشر هنا
القرار بدا يضع مثل هذه الاطر وهو اتصور
بان قرار موفق جدا وان كان متاخر ان جاء
جدا ممتازه كما ذكرت تتحدث عن الوهم الطبي
بمعنى ان الطبيب اليوم لا ينبغي الى نفس
المحامي المحامي لا ينبغي ي ذكر في
العنوان المكتب انه كان عميد حقوق سابق او
كان مستشار سابق او كان وزير سابق هذا امر
مرفوض لكن حقا تحتفظ العلمي فقط ولكن لا
يجوز لك ان تضع في الاعلان انك انت كنت
تتقلد وزاره سابقه او استشاره او ما شابه
ذلك هنا هنا الفاصل فقط لا غير او مثلا
تحط النو زباينك فلان وفلان وفلان وجولك
او اني انا والله يعني لاول مره يحدث هذه
العمليه نحن انا فقط اريد ان اقول بانه
انا لا اعيد فقط على الاطباء ولكن ايضا
اعيب على المحامين يعني حتى بعض المحامين
من يخرج بوسائل تواصل تواصل اجتماعي ويعمل
دعايه لنفسه دون مبرر وفي هذه الساعه ايضا
لادبيات ممارسه المهنه كان ياتي المحاميه
يقول انا ربحت دعوه نفقه
وخلعت زوجه وماذا بعد هذا ديدا قانون
الاحوال الشخصيه هناك خلع وهناك نفقه
وهناك للضرر وخلافه لكن عندما تحدث مثل
هذه الضجه انت لا تريد اليوم المشاركه في
المسؤوليه المجتمعيه اريد ان نعم
فكرتك نحنا شاكرين لك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا من الكويت المحامي الاستاذ
الدكتور فايز الكندري شكرا لك
في حوار تلفزيوني ممكن نسميه حوار ساخن
جدا منتشره مقاطع وحوار موساخن لانه شد في
الكلام وخلاص لا الموضوع وصل لدرجه طرد
ضيف من البرنامج وعلى الهواء مباشره
نحن الان نضيع وقت الحلقه نحن الان نحن
نحن الان
[موسيقى]
لانه فيها لانه في هذه اللهجه لهجه صغيره
احترم نفسك احترم نفسك
لو سمحت لو سمحت لو سمحت لو سمحتم لو سمحت
لو سمحت لو سمحت لو سمحت اما ناقش مع
احترام او تفضل هذا الحلقه لا هذا ولا حرف
ولا كلمه ولا كلمه ولا كلمه اما تناقش
باحترام وادب
او تغادر الحلقه اختر
الان تريد ان تكمل الحلقه لا ابدا
[موسيقى]
عيب عيب عيب عيب يا سيد عيب يا سيد عيب يا
سيد عيب يا سيد تفضل غدر الاستوديو عيب
هات الورق غدر
كل ما تقوم به سيظهر على الهواء ولن احذف
مقطعا واحدا لن احذف مقطعا واحدا تفضل
غادر الاستوديو لو سمحت من انتم تفضل تفضل
غدر الاستوديو تفضل غدا الاستديو تفضل غدا
الاستوديو تفضل غادر الاستوديو لو سمحت لو
سمحت هذا الاستوديو غدا الاستوديو غادر
الاستوديو هذه تصرفات صبيانيه ولن احذف اي
مقطع من هذه الحلقات كله
ضيوف بتنسحب من برامج على الهواء بس مذيع
يطرد ضيفه جديد اللي شفتوه كان جزء من
برنامج على قناه اورينت والنقاش كانت
المذيع احمد الريحاوي وبين ضيفوا المحلل
السياسي
التركيين اللي موجودين في تركيا وعن
ممارسات قوات الدرك التركيه بحقهم والعد
بيناتهم وقام المذيع قال الضيف مش اطلع
بره وعلى فكره كمان ترى الموضوع تطور
بزياده بعد انتهاء الحلقه في القناه اعلنت
في بيان من ساعات ان السلطات التركيه
اوقفت مدير القناه على فرحات ومقدمه
البرنامج من ليل الثلاثاء من بعد شكوى
رسميه تقدم فيها الضيف وقال بيان اورينت
ان التوقيف تم مباشره بعد تصوير الحلقه
وقبل الموعد عرضها بساعه كامله وقالت انه
الحلقه كامله من غير اي منتاج او اقتطاع
موجوده على المنصات وبتظهر كيف الضيف
التركي ووجه للمذيع عبارات عنصريه وفوقيه
وم ضده ضد السوريين وطالبت اورينت بمحاسبه
الضيف على عنصريته وقالت انها بتوثق
بعداله القضاء التركي المرصد السوري كمان
لحقوق الانسان دخل على الخط واصدر بيان
طالب فيه بالافراج الفوري عن المذيع
الموقوف في مركز امني بتركيا واما الناس
وتحديدا السوريين فردات فعلهم جات يعني
متباينه خلينا نقول في ناس في منصف القناه
والمذيع وشايفينه تصرف صح
وفي كمان اللي شايفين انه فعلا الضيف
كالمسيء ولكن انتقدوا ان المذيع اعترضوا
وقالوا ما يصير يعمل كده وفي شريحه كمان
ثالثه منتقده ومغلطه المذيع تماما وشايفه
انه تصرفه غير مهني على الاطلاق لانه حول
نفسه لطرف الخلاده
في احدى التطورات لقضيه سرقه فيلا لاعب
المنتخب المصري ونادي ليفربول محمد صلاح
اعلنت وزاره الداخليه من ساعات ان قبضت
على الحرميه اللي سرقوا الفيلا وقالت
الداخليه المصريه في بيانها انه تم القبض
على شخصين واحد منهم كان بيعمل عنصر امن
في نفس الكومباوند وانه اعترفوا بالسرقه
وانه هذا اللي كان يشتغل في الكومباوند
وبحكم سابق عمله فيه عارف مكان الفيلا
وعارف انه ما فيها احد لانهم مو في البلد
فخطت مع الثاني
للسرقه وتسلقوا ونطوا السور الخلفي ودخلوا
الفيلا اما بالنسبه للمسروقات الكثير كان
في تكهنات عنها وانه ممكن يكون من بينها
جائزه افضل لاعب في افريقيا فطلعت
الداخليه واعلنت انه المسروقات كانت
مجموعه من الاحذيه الرياضيه وميداليه فضيه
وقطعه من الكريستال وعدد من اجهزه الرسيفر
وانهم يستدعوا اللي بلغ عن السرقه وهو
مدير اعمال اللاعب وتعرف على المضبوطات
وتم توجيه تهمه او تهمه الس
للشخصين طبعا سرقه محمد صلاح كانت شغل
الناس من كم يوم وقت انتشرت اخبار وكان
ابن خالي اللاعب معدي من قدام الفيلا وشاف
الشباك مكسور فدخل الفيلا وشاف المكان
مكركب فبلغ السلطات فورا
في الجزائر في ظاهره الشغله الناس من
اسابيع وعامله حالها من القلق ففي بوستات
على المنصات واخبار بتقول انه تلاميذ في
المرحله الابتدائيه بيتعرضوا لوخس بقبر في
محيط المدرسه ومو معروف مين بيعمل كده او
ليه وجلست الاخبار متداوله هنا وزاره
العدل اصدرت بيان اعلنت في رصد خمس حالات
وخز لتلاميذ بابر في محيط مدارسهم كلهم
كان الوقت في يدهم اليسرى واللي بياخذهم
كانوا الستات واعلنت السلطات بانها بتبحث
وبتحقق في الموضوع ومين وراه وطلبت من
الاهالي تنبيه اولادهم انهم يبعدوا عن اي
غريب يقرب منهم بعدها بكم يوم طلع خبر عن
محاوله اختطاف لسيدتين لتلميذات في محيط
المدرسه ولقيوا معاهم ابر واعترفوا بسلطهم
مشعوذه معروفه وانقبض عليهم كلهم
[تصفيق]
بعد هذا الاعلان وصور الابر هذه الناس
قالت خلاص بانت الموضوع السحر وشعوذه وناس
تقول لا هذه محاولات خطف الدرج الوطني طلع
وهدى الناس وقال لهم انه بيعملوا كل ما في
وسعهم لضمان امنهم ودعاهم للتبليغ عن اي
حالات جديده وتجنب التهويل ونشر الدور
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم ان نعود
والقاكم الاسبوع المقبل ان شاء الله في
امان الله
[موسيقى]